[Música]
o psol serviço é mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um carregador do
telemóvel portátil que usa como fonte de
energia é a vossa temperatura corporal e
eu tenho aqui é para substituir aquilo
que eu disse que ia colocar conferir um
avião foi pequena em 3d que voa e o
problema é que houve ou não vou então
tive que arranjar uma solução e eu acho
que esse projeto deveria ficar melhor se
usássemos 10 placas destas e colocada
numa mala naquela para tem que ficar em
contacto com as costas eu digo que nessa
parte porque normalmente as pessoas
andarem distâncias aquecem muito aquela
passagem entre a mala e as costas e
assim acho que seria suficiente para
criar uma tensão equivalente a um
carregador do telemóvel normal isso
seria ideal para os viajantes que se não
carregar o telemóvel tal é o computador
talvez não funcione
as lanternas já seria possível é em
placas e que custou mais ou menos de
dois dólares online e é bastante fácil
de encontrar à venda e que está a
demonstração de como isto funciona
extensão por vos dar se uma ideia geral
e pode ser feito com estas placas aqui é
e uma coisa também por cento sobre elas
é que vocês da energia é um dos lados
vai ficar muito quente e outro lado vai
ficar muito frio e por um só os
cãezinhos campo no estado desta idéia
nos comentários
seria interessante vocês deixarem idéias
do que vocês fariam com estes placas iiz
muito obrigada tecido até a próxima